على كل لمزيد من المتابعه ايضا اذهب الى
دمشق ينضم اليهم هناك المتحدث باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا عدنان
حزام استاذ عدنان اهلا وسهلا بك اي تقييم
للوضع الان في اليوم السادس لهذا الزلزال
المدمر واي سوره يمكن ان تنقلها الينا
سواء على مستوى عدد الضحايا اخر تحديث
للارقام التي وردتكم عدد الجرحى عدد
المشردين وابرز الاحتياجات التي يعني يجب
ان تحصلوا عليها باسرع وقت ممكن لاغاثه
الجرح
طبعا
الوضع
يزداد صيدليه خاصه انه هناك فرص قليله
لاحتمال وجود ناجين مع ذلك تستمر هذه
العمليات عمليه الانقاذ وكذلك عمليه تقديم
العمل الانساني
لضحايا هذه الكارثه خاصه
المدينه التي حلب واللاذقيه وحماه تقبل
السليب الاحمر مع فرق الهلال الاحمر
بالتوزيع المواد الغذائيه وكذلك الايوائيه
لمن هم في هذه المراكز طبعا ما نقدمه هو
شيء بسيط
مقارنه بالوضع الحالي والاحتياجات الكبيره
والعدد الهائل من الاسر المتواجده في تلك
المراكز للاسف الشديد الوضع الانساني بهذه
الكارثه
صعب للغايه ومحزن كثير نحن نحن نحاول قدر
المستطاع التقديم من هذه من هذه من اثر
هذه استاذ عدنان يعطيكم الف عافيه بطبيعه
الحال هذا العمل الانساني لو تعطينا بعض
المعلومات عدد القوافل المساعدات التي
وصلتكم وكيف يتم توزيعها يعني تصل في
الوقت المحدد ام لا في تحديات عم بتواجهكم
في موضوع توزيع هذه المساعدات
طبعا نحن في اللهجه الدولي بالاحمر لدينا
الياتنا في عمليه التوزيع كوننا لدينا
كوننا موجودين في هذه البلد التي تعاني من
اكثر من 12 عاما من النزاع نقوم
باخراج المواد من المخازن وتقديمها
للمتضررين طبعا ما قدمناه لا يفي بالغرض
ولذلك سيكون هناك المزيد في الايام
القادمه خاصه المواد الايوائيه والجراحيه
والطبيه والغذائيه بتعرف يعني في في وضع
يعني الوضع في سوريا وضع غير طبيعي لانه
في مناطق قاضعه للحكومه في مناطق خاضعه
لمقاتلي المعارضه اولا كيف يعني بالنسبه
الى المناطق الخاضعه التي ليست خاضعه
لسيطره الحكومه السوريه هل لديكم داله على
المساعدات هناك ارسال المساعدات اليهم
توزيع المساعدات هناك ام لا لا وجود لاي
قنوات تواصل
طبعا من اللجنه الدوليه الصليب الاحمر حتى
قبل هذه
الكارثه تحاول الوصول للمناطق الاخرى
التي تعاني من الازمه وكذلك الان
نقوم بالتواصلاتنا من اجل الوصول لجميع
المناطق المتاثره بهذا بهذه الكارثه طبعا
اريد ان اوضح هنا ان هناك منظمات كثيره
تعمل على الارض السوريه
والعمل الانساني متكامل سواء كان في شماله
او غربها او جنوبها الوقت الوقت الان جاء
لصوت الانساني يجب ان يكون هناك السمح
لدخول المزيد من المساعدات وان يكون هناك
تقديم للمساعده وتسير عمليه عمل المنظمات
الانسانيه من دمشق المتحدث باسم اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في سوريا عدنان
حزام شكرا جزيلا
حزامه ويعطيكم الف عافيه